[Musique]
prise de cavalier nous sommes à Arsenal
hors contemporain où vous vous
réincarnez dans le délogie now de
l'artiste loup wine c'est une
performance de capture de mouvement en
direct un peu manga jeux vidéo qu'est-ce
qui est venu vous chercher dans ce
projet là en fait pourquoi je fais des
projets des fois c'est complètement
intuitif ça peut être un second le
premier 10 secondes d'une rencontre puis
là c'était la rencontre avec un courriel
de Alex Thibault puis qui m'envoie la
vidéo de louyam celle qui était fait à
Shanghai que danseur japonais j'ai vu je
pense j'ai regardé 10 secondes puis il y
a un personnage qui était absurde
ridicule et un peu dramatique aussi puis
ça me donnait une opportunité de
d'essayer quelque chose de complètement
différent avant l'entrevue je vous
disais que tous les deux on est étudié
au collège de bois de Boulogne ça a été
la danse puis j'avais jamais regardé en
arrière puis vous avez foncé droit
devant moi c'est pas une décision que
j'ai pris danser ces deux c'est arrivé
naturellement j'étais aussi je bois de
Boulogne oui mais j'étais en sciences
j'ai fait de la danse parce que j'en
avais fait un peu au secondaire j'ai
continué un peu au cégep je me sors je
fais de la danse en attendant en
attendant de trouver ce que je dois
faire mais j'étais forte en sciences
j'étais forte en maths
avec les je peux pas mais moi je peux
pas m'imaginer justement dans un travail
comme ça mais je mets l'abstraction je
pense en fait c'est que j'aimais
l'abstraction alors c'est pas si loin de
la danse finalement ça s'est rejoint
on le voit dans le documentaire Louise
le cavalier sur son cheval de feu vous
devez voir à la maison d'ailleurs on
vous voit méditer faire un peu de box
bien vous alimentez aussi c'est tout ça
le cosmos que vous créez autour de vous
pour vous permettre encore aujourd'hui
de monter sur scène
c'est assez simple quand même parce que
j'ai fait ça tellement d'années danser
m'entraîner de toutes sortes de façon
avec du ballet de la temporelle
j'ai fait aussi du yoga j'ai fait de la
boxe je fais une entraînement de gym
fait de la course mais c'est comme si
c'est un peu inclus dans mon corps
maintenant
comme je danse encore je travaille à
chaque jour physiquement ça me paraît
pas une spinardie comme naturelle mais
je suis pas obsédé par ça
[Musique]
je dois absolument se poser la question
parce que j'écoute du devis de Bauer
peut-être une fois par jour c'est
vraiment une de mes grandes idoles
artistiques pour toutes sortes de
raisons et vous avez travaillé avec
alors comment c'était comment il était
un être que j'ai beaucoup aimé c'est
très touchant
des fois on peut pas s'imaginer ça de
quelqu'un qui est si connu mais quand
j'ai rencontré j'ai une femme accès
direct à la personne très direct j'avoue
que de se sentir aimé de quelqu'un comme
lui c'est ben ça touche une place qui
reste comme précieuse et inviolable
après je veux pas qu'elle arrête de dire
dans le film Louise le cavalier sur son
cheval de feu vaut deux filles disent on
veut pas que maman arrête de danser
qu'est-ce que vous leur avez je pense
qu'est-ce que vous avez à leur répondre
je suis pas redevable aux autres même à
mes propres filles je pars de ma dent
c'est pas devant
je pense que elles ont dit ça parce que
pensaient elles me voient heureuse à
faire mon travail
c'est extrêmement gentil de leur part de
dire ça de dire nous on accepte que pas
toujours là mais en fait je suis
beaucoup là quand même je disais intégré
enfin beaucoup à ma vie tournée etc puis
maintenant ils sont plus vieilles ils
n'ont pas besoin de beaucoup surtout que
si ils ont 21 ans maintenant donc
c'était mignon qui est dit ça mais ça me
fait pas une pression la pression je
suis capable de la mettre toute seule
sur les épaules Louise le cavalier merci
beaucoup avec plaisir
[Musique]